stop right what you doing I need you to
do something for me all right
I can't be here just whatever you do
don't tell my SIA
oh oh oh oh oh me oh my potato salad pie
okay
so I get to pick which girl I want to
hire for my camstudio now I don't know
what a camstudio is
but I'm gonna go with my girl TIFF a
TIFF to the tip okay so we got Tiffany
finest quality of fresh meat so we put
her in the camstudio over here and she
will start making his money by skyping
to people nothing weird why does why
does his studio look like jacksepticeye
so she's making his money five bucks
TIFF eh that's not that much what we
also have to do is we have to get a
photo shoot should we get more fans see
they gave us five fans all right so now
we can buy so we can have two girls at
once all right who should we go with
Nikki nut Nadia or Zoe what the [ __ ]
happened Zoe this is not the fifth
element Zoe get the [ __ ] out we're going
with Nadia she might be a man but at
least she doesn't look like a [ __ ]
tumblr girl is it hot in here am i
sweating all right let's get another
girl
yeah we got Sarah she's got a thick ass
uh got Audrey she's a teen we got Lyle
on e she's Asian how holy Lola why am I
so into this game this is merely a
cookie clicker
but I'm so into it oh all right so we
can look at our fans her friends are
into thick-ass I can respect that right
I think we're gonna grow the thick-ass
Sarah is an unbearable rear boo who
thinks she's Japanese and calls herself
Suki
she's the worst but she's still kind of
hot in a weird way okay we're gonna have
to recruit someone you the cast we're
gonna have to go with the thick ass
we're niching in thick ass all right I
hate to do this but we're gonna have to
replace our main [ __ ] cafe we're go
we're the thick ass studio she pulls in
so many fans that [ __ ] kowai kowai
girl man
yes I am having the time of my life shut
the [ __ ] get a thick ass then we can
talk to Paige ever go to heaven I want I
want this game to be my life all right
what are fans into they love thick ass
we're gonna be rich we're gonna be rich
so now we can advertise our camstudio
cake barking don't look up cake farts
it's not worth it
listen we have thick assets of course
we're gonna fart on cakes what the [ __ ]
kind of business do you think we're
running here if you don't do cake
farting you're out of the game I'm
really glad I'm watching this screen and
not the camp's it is green that's that's
what I would have I prefer it this way
thank you thank you very much pleasure
yep we can buy a butt plug
all right who's shoot I have the butt
plug this is the best yeah they're the
weeaboo gets the bus like whoever
whoever came up with the idea of this
game is a goddamn genius okay now we
gotta lily and I love her some more
wealthy customers have requested a
private one-on-one meeting with the
girls wait so I can send my girls to a
sleazy motel Wow good job game you
continue to amaze me we can have cake
farts all right let's get the cake parts
let's make this latina girl get some
cake parts she likes it let's invest in
cake party
don't tell Marcia for the love of God
about cake farts Jesse oh yeah oh my god
yes all right lot now let's promo
forbidden cave and anal hopefully should
you make a lot of money on this sleazy
hotel not yet you're going again yeah
she's Russian she's okay with it she's
got Connery yeah look at me I'm a mess
what's wrong with me I have a girlfriend
keep clicking I can't click fast enough
I can't collect fast enough I can't
believe the most annoying [ __ ] girl
in the whole world
it's got the most fans I'm so [ __ ]
into this game it's pathetic but I love
it oh we got reen she's got a thick ass
what they should say koala god I'm so
tired of collecting this game is
horrible and sexist and I hate it it's
ruining my life I'm out
what happened what are you kidding me
that just randomly happened I am NOT
some [ __ ] level a great pant
what hey it's okay it's okay I got to
see tape a best best game I feel like
this game has changed me this is not who
I am I heard my kidding make sure your
ass is waxed next time Tiffany